well Americans rack up trillions of
miles in points every single year using
travel loyalty programs and credit cards
with rewards an estimated 15 percent of
those miles and points expire or go
unused now the points guy a trowel
website tracks 43 programs monthly to
see which ones offer the best value per
mile or point Brian Kelly is founder and
CEO of the points guy and first on CBS
this morning he is releasing his August
report you're releasing it early for us
just for you guys
good morning so I don't get it what
aren't people using their miles you know
I think the biggest thing is people
don't realize how valuable they are you
know frequent flyer miles credit card
points their currency and that's what we
want to let people know you know people
may say I only have 10,000 points
they're worthless but they're actually
not it could be hundreds or thousands of
dollars sitting right below your nose
and that's what we want to get consumers
to realize that's my husband's refrain
oh they're not they're not worth
anything but I get so many trips at it
exactly and then there's some people who
just like to hoard them how do you say
they're worth a lot but in your report
it says they're only worried about one
cent each but notes up to two cents
apiece and that's it but you know but
get you can get fifty to a hundred
thousand points just from opening up a
single credit card so the fact is yes
you can earn more miles and points today
from everyday spending you don't have to
be a frequent flyer they're all around
us and what we want to let people is
like get in on the value because it can
save you it so what are the some
creative ways to make sure you use this
stuff so if you've got like credit card
points you want to see if they transfer
to partner so if you use your credit
card points for gift cards you're
probably getting the least amount of
value if you transfer to airline
partners you can get huge value
especially when redeeming for first or
business class especially international
so the key thing is for flights buy the
cheap flights but save your points for
those really expensive ones you know
there's a there's a between those of us
who travel quite a bit you know some are
one airline over a number another you
know who's the best one are you gonna
tell us and to like Wendy when should
you drop one to go for another one I
think the thing to note airlines have
partners so of the major airlines
you know the actual what's the best
airline itself service and food I mean
that's all up for debate depend on what
you want but united airlines are our
most valuable main you know the top
carriers because they are star alliance
which means they've got twenty really
good global partners they've got a
pretty good website that's another thing
we we rate airlines on because some
airlines have really valuable miles but
their websites are terrible so that's
why consumers go on and say oh I can
never use my points yeah I think that
you can a lot of times you have to pick
up the phone and call so we give more
value to the programs that make it
easier to redeem so easy so you
mentioned these offers four points are
everywhere so how does a person take
advantage of the point offers without
being taken advantage of how many should
they sign up for you know there's no
magic number I would say you know if you
get you know one or two credit cards but
it's not just a sign up bonus what
credit cards look at the bonuses some
will give Forex on dining or 5x on
airfare so look at what you spend your
money on and then get the credit cards
your goal is to earn more than one point
for every dollar spent and with so many
different options out there it's easy if
you start you know you know even put a
post-it note on your credit card use
this one for gas this one for
supermarket it may seem silly I like
that idea
but when you're earning 4 X 5 X like it
they start to add up very quickly and
some of these rewards programs you can
buy things but I've been told that's
actually about the worst way to yes
you're buying merchandise it's if it's
really easy in general it's not worth it
another way to earn miles is a lot of
times these programs sell miles at a
discount so you know if you want to stay
in Paris at a really fancy Hyatt Hotel
it can make sense to buy points and
redeem versus paying for it outright
it's sort of like an arbitrage mode
that's more of like an advanced tactic
but are I buy points all the time you
buy them on the cheap and then you
redeem for you know Emirates first-class
and take a shower at 40,000 feet in this
guy you should be a date race requires a
great deal of a time investment this
whole point thing Brian Kelly thank you
very much